il mio libro storie paurose a scola di
misteri e ora disponibile per il pre
ordine su amazon preordina l'ho subito
sono stati così come si bacia mezzo è
l'ultimo che esce dal cerchio perde o no
aspetta in senso che cerca vincere
dovevamo riuscire a rimanere il dentro
al cerchio per più tempo possibile
però succederanno in ogni turno
succederà qualcosa che in modo che
usciamo fuori dal cerchio perché va
davanti a uno stato come un grammo
farete lasciato bel mi piace quattr'otto
primo round ecco vedete questo rosso è
il cerchio ok capito siamo in tantissimi
sono tantissimi giocatori quando salti
fa le cose io pensavo che stavo
scoraggiando
ma è diffuso a lo vuole sa che appare
una bianco ma dove sei non ti trovo ci
sono troppe persone
sì effettivamente ei sono qui
perché mi sono fermato
allora quel cerchio rosso noi dobbiamo
cercare per più tu per più giorni
possibili di rimanere qua dentro
anche se c'è scritto che arriveranno dei
meteoriti dai 100 maggiori ti
aiuto praticate un meteorite in testa
buoni mezzi che risposto allora
è ancora vivo pensi
aiuto wow che figlio siamo sopravvissuti
futuro
siamo ancora
a
comparire campomarino
dopo di rubarlo
non so
chi ha prezzo già due volte
per non farti trascinare fuori per la
ecco perché ogni volta c'è un ostacolo
diverso per farti trascinare pur in un
armadio ma è anche un paniere che fanno
mangiare o forse siamo riusciti a
superare anche questo ostacolo
sistemi non mi piace fare una seconda
parte di prova a rimanere dentro al
secchio aspetta mi stanno sparando i
meteoriti io non ti vedo un
aspirapolvere st peron euro vitale che
salta con il parere ma non lo mollerebbe
per niente al mondo
che ci il cerchio si trasformava il
trampolino a c'è scritto un trampolino
ma quando adesso è così c'era scritto
salta salta salta salta
c'è scritto che il primo che riesce a
salire pin su prenderanno so chi è ma
quanti fanno cascare abbiamo trovato
tantissimi giocando come rosolino
è sparita gli scatti riuscirà a vincere
c'è scritto che il gp a stiletto c'è un
gioco per ogni primato un gigante lei mi
dice che ho davvero non lo metti sistri
stretto quindi si restringerà sempre di
più e sono di noi rimarrà dentro cerchio
riusciremo a vincere e vitale che cosa
sono questi tuo tornado
tornano
perché c'è questo sì che non lo so dare
gigante
cosa che ci schiaccia e non tornano
per praticamente cacciato cioè non c'è
più ma siamo riusciti a sopravvivere
anche al tornato non si torna poi
tornato è tornato è tornato che viene
adesso non ho capito ma per succedere
qualcosa c'è c'è un phon acceso c'è
scritto
così c'è scritto
lo sentivo e se rimane fermo ti muovi
verso l'esterno del sì perché ti
spingono a no c'è il vento a perché c'è
il fondo accesa lo vedi
siamo arrivati in 21 voglio vincere
voglio ripagare il cerchio fino alla
fine la cosa vedere cosa vi in qualcosa
per strare di tutte che io sono ancora
in vita non riesco a combinare ancora
colpa mia ma non vedete non c'è tempo
per mangiare
ma di un momento di musica di narrazione
ma sempre stato prima dei meteoriti e si
è scritto di nuovo c'è
un treno
per di un rosone annunciamo il resto il
treno ma preso me to return no
qui si è uscito fuori dal ceravolo sono
ancora né certo né rumore
siamo rimasti in 18
piano piano vengono eliminati sempre più
giocatori credo che noi stiamo ancora
bari
che succede niente ho preso un meteorite
in pieno
siamo fra no
sono caduto giù scritto che dobbiamo
spingere gli altri pulita al cerchio ma
non è facile ma che vi si è distrutto
c'è qualcuno che non rimasi solo in 16
che succede l'acqua c'è stare qua
io no e per essere tutto è legato o no
perché mi hanno spinto devo spinto per
miracolo si chiama for abili un vulcano
apparirà in un secondo è mancato un
vulcano
abbiamo salvato il portiere ma vediamo
cosa sta succedendo io ero sulla
mongolfiera non capisco ecco in casa
paragono nova vedi se prima sui 14 come
è possibile che siamo crearli b non sto
chiedendo anch'io
questo gioco fa venire un sacco di ansia
lascia proprio col fiato sospeso e lento
temete che cos'altro lasciato il piatto
sospetto
scuola di mister e se non avete ancora
preordinato andate subito a preordinarlo
perché i primi che prima tira nella
libro mi copro fermeranno anche una
cartolina per l'invio auto proprio anche
quello di pitone quindi correte subito a
preordino al nostro del dottore che vi
lasceranno incollati corpi sa tutto di
tutti
siamo rimasti punti ci siamo rimasti
ruby non ci credo ma vincere io in vita
le comunque sono quasi porto io
l'atteggia non ti far prendere dagli ufo
è tornato anche il vulcano che questo
gioco non lascia un attimo di tregua
allora lavorava il vulcano che il dottor
estesa genius
citate che c'è scritto che è diventato
un genere amata diventare un gene
codificante il cerchio si sta dal 63
puntate struggendo poi dopo piccolissimo
proprio aiuto non so se ce la faremo a
riaccogliere in vita quando è cercata da
piccolissimo scappa dagli ufo tu che sei
un genio
spingere gli altri fuori
concetto non questo gioco veramente
venire l'ansia non cambiando riesco a
capire presto che mi restaurato
ma tu che sei gigante non puoi non può
stare solo
siamo ancora vivi non saltare sulle mine
qualcuno attento ci sono delle linee se
tu ci vai sopra esploderanno attento
questo fermo fermo qui nerbo per roma
per molte leve di un anno di tregua
gravity coil
e che sta per succedere voi non lo so
cosa è successo ma io sono ancora
gigante ci sono ancora le mine perché
sono ancora gigante e ora che devo fare
poco pillow fight wow
cuscino
e lo dico io combatto contro
che è successo è tornato aggiornato
guardo una rotta una ruspa si siamo
rimasti in dieci a ballare la
discesa vanno queste cose dobbiamo
salire sopra
bianchi io ok stiamo qua sopra
e ora che succede
il movimento della felicità salire solo
sarà poco poco salati bravo meno malata
si chiamava serve giganti estate sopra
un piccolino
comunque stasera tenere il portello è
una e una spada il cerchio si sta
restringendo una vasta in sette questo
gioco non la somma di tutto perché mi
spingono aiuto aiuto cerca piccolissimo
detto aiuto un robot che non ci staremo
più qua dentro siamo rimasti io sono
piccolino potevi stare del so
c'è 2 marini non ci credo
ma felicissimo staccate farini perché ha
cambiato colore quel che è successo
se la met e due panini ad est ha rivolto
il vulcano sulla merda del vulcano
bisceglie mai dobbiamo riuscire a
vincere in italia dobbiamo vincere
stanno per arrivare i meteoriti mi
chiamo io lo leggo no battitori e
mettile no aspetta e vulcano e non so
come mi chiedo quanto vedo i meteoriti
agli un
cerchio pittore trento ed autore di più
perché questo è il gioco più caotico
questo momento
ancora vivi e stiamo ancora vivi credo
che siamo ancora vivi ma i meteoriti
stanno cadendo tutti in questo spaziato
piccolo piccolo il vulcano è il vulcano
quartiere è stato eliminato a me sei
aiuto dobbiamo fare dei suoi 5 ae
dobbiamo vincere dobbiamo vincere ce la
faremo lasciate un mi piace per portarsi
fortuna però presentarvi di boyle che
non so che cos'è
manifestanti invece a volare per
dare a chi stava se vinciamo se
rimaniamo l'altro il cerchio attento
treno mentre hanno centro e renault dove
è passato già
adesso lo farà se il treno non farti
piacere le altre hanno da noi sta
saltando con brevi de coelo
siamo quasi alla fine attenta atleta ci
sono queste cose che cos'è la carne
aiuto che ha
schiacciato
sì siamo rimasti quattro pure non mi ha
spiazzato
solo per arrivare primo superiore di
reciproci cosa facciamo e quanto primo
novecento hai mai
visto purtroppo ancora passato da
spettatore a vitale
speriamo che è vitale vincoli sono stata
sia accettata dal treno massi sono
quattro persone da evitare poi farsi una
cui parte la facciamo tutti sono
diventato
primo capitale vincano le possa
schiacciare questione non l'ho finita al
cerchio kate ma è molto attento bene dai
che la forza del panino si è
mosso schiacciare questi dai da fare che
cosa è quello qualcuno avrà una spada
fra poco quindi stai attento perché
potrebbero aspettarti dice io e lo
schiacciatore
qualcuno vai affettiamo li mettiamo
tutti carta vinco io
[Risate]
ho instaurato il bagno rimasto il panino
attento a non farti prendere nonno
tommaso più grande e io degli ufo non
siete ancora in quattro e strettissimo
questo cerchio che anzi avvicinò a me
piace vincere o no un altro punto di ufo
non hanno preso nessuno ancora c'è anche
la neve adesso al traffico spero di non
scivolare allora qualcuno è sparito
qualcuno è sparito nella botola no
sorpresa
niente più cerchio sul petto ok solo
cerchio per un pelo c'è mancato poco il
cerchio si è stretto ancora di più
guardato solo vincere per lavori 4 che
cos'è una scala presto salita ci provo
io non riesco mai a salire su queste
scale primati arrivi l'acqua ok rimane
fermo lino che in ci provo che è
arrivata l'acqua il marito ma non la
nega nessuno qui c'è dice di ricevere
ottava tra questi quattro ancora nessuno
è stato eliminato
c'è si sente ancora di più prego tali
policy saranno tre mesi era poco
con i missili
hanno colpito queste famiglie cerchio
non so quanto mi è rimasto di
ricerche 63 di più
adesso gli ufo dovranno prendere
qualcuno io non mi avvicino più ancora
vento non ti avvicinare in certi
diventerà un trampolino adesso salta
tre missili stanno per attaccare il
cerchio spero non me li ho visti io ho
visti non hanno preso nessuno ok bravo
pavimento diciamo che siamo rimasti in
tre sedi remote in treno non posso
crederci non aver eliminato uno se vince
vitale forse vince prova a spingere gli
altri pure dal cerchio dice
no no
no non riesco più a salire
foto per me erano un pelo ce l'hai fatta
chi sarà il prossimo
solo in tre una manina esplosiva attento
non calpestate
dai puoi farcela puoi farcela vitale poi
pace
o non tornavo sei tornado attenti
attenta a trento trento che
il bologna
a presto nessuno dei due ok il cerchio
si sta restringendo ora è una battaglia
tra voi due
da evitare facciamo tutti il tifo per te
riesce a entrare nello spazio che
succede non lo so troppo contorno è
tornato un tornado è tornato il tornado
tranne truciolo dentro cerchio sono
dentro c'è più che anzi ansia o
costaricano
non so che se uno scarpone punto di
ritardo dai tre cerchio pretto ok hai
vinto tu
devo correre
come ho fatto
un contribuito
come tantissimi siamo più di 30.000
vinto trova questa partita lavorate un
mi piace loro la partita è vi ricordo di
preordinare attore parole a scuola tv
ora vi lasciamo quattro le sale non
cliccare prove degli oltre altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite buona
visione ciao